how far do you predict the tectonic
plates will move or churn
before tectonic activities stop on Earth
so Mars
has is it 1 8 Hour surface area and
generally you radiate the heat through
your surface okay Mars has no tectonic
activity we think it may have at one
point but it's completely cooled so I'm
just wondering maybe we have to be
around eight times as long as Mars has
been to reach the state that Mars is in
right now or whenever Mars had stopped
its activity I think that makes a lot of
sense uh the the general consensus right
now is that Mars's tectonic activity
stopped about one to two billion years I
believe after it Formed which means that
we have somewhere between say 10 and 20
billion years worth of tectonics going
on